all right welcome to new video five
minute games again and I'm playing yeah
Maradona but is not from Argentina but
from Russia is a really a veteran ICC
player I played him for ages
okay um he went for Kings Indian here
okay place ninety-one okay it's sort of
neat to play this from what I know which
is not too much but this is all all
normal like now I usually goes for this
kind of who knew over here know c7 I
think I need to cover and now I think he
can take on a seven if he wants to okay
a question I was mmm it's a six a mafia
hmm is a six alluvion what about just
Bishop d7 57 Knight c7 I should have
rook c8 okay just retreats in six I'm
I'm not so sure because it weakens b6 he
would go not a three c4 or something
like this hmm okay but now let's make
some active moves here trying to get
something going against White's King
okay white rice for this sideways
defense
because that so that the route can
actually do something on the
third-ranked I'm not sure that I can
manage without this knight on f6 okay
but this should be okay anyway so maybe
still a theoretical position okay I'll
play this after all don't want to worry
about night c7 all the time okay now a
five might be the idea
Shapiro's pc8 first the Fife is coming
or should I play G form hard to tell ya
that I guess it shows a bit that I'm not
an expert on this so spending a bit too
much time also looks a bit weird but
he's playing everything instantly
oopsie seven now it's I know it's not
the usual plan but I'm not sure that
this is so terrible for me okay
so takes him maybe this is still still
okay it's not what black wants to do but
maybe it's still so quite solid I can
try to play but should be 78 to to give
this bishop a useful role and the thing
is that white doesn't have so many yeah
he's only Scott this before before be
five idea I'm at the moment this bishop
hangs though so I think you will play on
something like Bishop you won maybe yeah
this also doesn't do much on edge form
okay
so do I have some possibility to bring
the special to the edge my to b5 would
be nice as is possible I try I try to do
this maybe is too quick before b5 coming
instantly
okay okay prevented this but it's not
like you made so much progress over the
last couple of news should I exchange
I'm not sure that I have something
better also try to reroute the bishop
twin-seat to am cover it you know time
is an issue of course not that some
position is to to great party
okay okay why this is the better but if
this is a witness questionable maybe
mmm-hmm not sure still want to go and be
fine
we exchanged all nights not sure if why
then still has something I don't think
so really you can try to get to the
forum but I can also just go to a 6cm
yeah what now
before it's an immediate draw it should
be six also and he is not playing on
time I know this if it's a dead dead
draw like everything's closed down you
will he will make it wrong so that's it
really
it's a draw don't see what white should
do and just grab a five or if he protect
us I can go King a seven and a six
I should have played h4 draw offer game
draw yeah yeah I know him he doesn't
play on time in such a silly position
yeah it was not the greatest game but
like and not what what you aim for in
King's Indian but I'm not I don't know
the theory I know this this is kind of
known but maybe you need to to play G
for as a pawn SEC at some point like
here I'm not sure maybe there's
something like this like g4 here I'm not
I don't know the way I played it was
just a question if it holds or not and
most likely with some better play by
white he could have been close to to
winning at some point it was critical
anyway now I'm paying but I think it's a
fair result maybe all right next game